bonsoir victor mendes merci d'être avec
nous vous étiez donc la manifestation
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas franchement été
suivi un pour quelles raisons selon vous
quel message vous vous leviez délivré
aujourd'hui on a vu devant le ministère
non seulement supérieur là où des
conseillers de vidal pour organiser ou
demander des soirées parce que le
semestre a juste été catastrophique en
ce moment les étudiants ils sont en
train de réviser leur part cm en train
de préparer leur part cm et l'on a fait
le choix de malgré cet obstacle
ce qu'on a tous des ports série dette
devant le ministère c'est la quatrième
ou cinquième échéance de mobilisation
depuis le début de l'année 2021 parce
que la situation est dramatique c'est à
dire qu'on est en france sixième
puissance mondiale et en laisse sa
jeunesse à sacrifier notre génération
un étudiant sur six qui décroche d'après
un rapport des sénateurs mais il forme
de troubles dépressifs qui explose chez
les jeunes entre 18 et 24 ans
des étudiants qui met fin à leurs jours
et rien qui les fait façon conséquente
pour régler ça wayne on ira avec ou sans
examen rendre visite à un ministre parce
que ce n'est tout simplement pas
acceptable et on est fiers de cette
journée de mobilisation nationale
vous avez montré des images à lyon y
compris avec des fonctions avec des
salariés de la santé et on va se battre
on va se battre toute l'année et la
bagarre c'est déjà pour être sûrs que
nos facs est l'heureux ouvre au plus
vite dès le prochain semestre avec du
son pour son présentiel et des moyens
des places pour tous alors effectivement
là vous m'arrêtez si jamais trompé a
pris c'est une journée de cours en
présentiel les repas un euro au resto u
et ce n'est pas suffisant pour vous
qu'est ce que vous demandez au
gouvernement bah écoutez quand vous avez
santé publique france qui dit que
en fait les jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans
donc c'est gouvernement a qui disent ça
sont publiquement en france c'est le
gouvernement les jeunes entre 18 et 24
ans sont ceux qui sont les plus touchés
par les formes de troubles dépressifs
nous on ne peut pas être satisfait des
cours en présentiel à 20% ce n'est pas
même pas une journée c'est à 20% dans
tous les établissements faire quel
établissement il doit choisir les
étudiants qui auront des cours en
présentiel et ceux qui n'en auront pas
ce qui a comme concrètement comme
conséquence alors il ya des filières
nous allemands nous dit tous les
étudiants pourront revenir une fois par
semaine à la fac c'est pas vrai c'est
pas du tout vrai il ya des filières
entières qui depuis en fait maintenant
octobre n'ont pas connu de représente
présentiel et c'est dramatique
ça aurait été possible ce semestre ou de
garantir du centre sont présents c'est
sans mettre en danger la vie des
étudiants et de ceux qui travaillent
mais ça aurait nécessité d'embaucher des
enseignants devrait ouvrir dès de louer
des locaux pour qu'il puisse y avoir des
cours sans qu'ils aient de kloster son
pied de contamination et ça ça veut dire
mettre des moyens ce que ce gouvernement
refuse de faire et nous c'est le combat
qu'on mène c'est la raison pour laquelle
on était devant ce ministère parce qu'on
pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est possible de
garder on peut soit disant s'entasser
dans des rer sont tassés au boulot pour
les salariés mais on pourrait pas
garantir des cours en présentiel
houllier ddm d un cork très réduite de
10 étudiants par exemple
oui on pourrait oui on pourrait mais ça
me va ça nécessiterait de mettre
beaucoup d'argent pour embaucher des
enseignants pour louer des locaux pour
assurer le respect des mesures
sanitaires et c'est ce problème là c'est
ça que le gouvernement ne veut pas faire
il ne veut pas mettre d'argent frais non
seulement supérieur clairement
aujourd'hui vous me l'avez dit les
problèmes psychologiques de la
dépression chez les étudiants mais aussi
un très fort risque de décrochage
c'est le cas au pont de vaux bien sûr
bien sûr on a en fait des cours sur
steam ce lorsque tu dois apprendre par
exemple des langues et que tu as tant
traîné à l'oral entraîner
vocabulaire et que tu le seul rapport
que tu as avec ton enseignants c'est un
échange sur un ordinateur lorsque des
étudiants qui sortent du bac qui n'ont
croisé qui viennent d'arriver à la fac
qui n'ont pas de nom pas connu leur
promotion n'ont pas connu leur camarade
de classe bah c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de pouvoir suivre en fait une
année dans ces situations là est donc la
conséquence concrète c'est qu'il ya des
gens qui ont clairement un bond de l'est
ils ont d'autant plus avons donné que
beaucoup parmi nous on fait perdu toute
forme de revenus que ce soit parce
qu'ils ont perdu leur emploi ou parce
que leurs proches ont perdu leur emploi
et se retrouve à devoir trouver des
moyens pour faire de l'argent ou un
devoir vivre de distribution alimentaire
et tout ça ça entrave
en fait le bon déroulement de nos de nos
études et la réalité c'est que ça me
dérange pas ce gouvernement ce problème
là ça ne les dérange pas victor mendes
une dernière question est ce que ce que
vous décrivez très bien à la fac est ce
que c'est le cas dans des écoles comme
les écoles de commerce ou des écoles
privées est ce que c'est la même chose
les étudiants français chez eux
également il n'y a pas de présentiel
on c'est différent écoutez je moi j'ai
pas de vision détaillée sur l'ensemble
des écoles privées c'est pas trop mon
invité le combat qu'on mène disponible
un site est gratuite ouverte à tous ces
publics
mais c'est clair que la majorité de ces
étudiants de ce que l'on voit ont connu
des courants distant ciel et c'est
purement scandaleux alors qu'il ya des
que ce soit dans le privé au public
d'ailleurs mais c'est d'autant plus
scandaleux dans le public parce que ce
serait par l'état on voit qu'il ya 500
milliards qui auraient été donnés à des
grandes entreprises en aide publique ne
peut pas donner le début d'une somme
aussi importante pour les universités
nous on va se battre dans les semaines
et mois à venir pour obtenir ça on est
fier d'avoir été aujourd'hui dans la rue
parce que c'est un combat extrêmement
important pour que les jeunes ne paye
pas les conséquences de ces crises avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france